so i have here a three-dimensional graph
and that means that it's representing
some kind of function that has a
two-dimensional input and a
one-dimensional output so that might
look something like
f of x
y
equals and then just some expression
that has a bunch of x's and y's in it
and graphs are great but they're kind of
clunky to draw i mean certainly you
can't just scribble it down it typically
requires some kind of graphing software
and when you take a static image of it
it's not always clear what's going on so
here i'm going to describe a way that
you can represent these functions in
these graphs two-dimensionally just by
scribbling down on a two-dimensional
piece of paper
and this is a very common way that
you'll see if you're
reading a textbook or if someone is
drawing on a blackboard it's known as a
contour plot
and the idea of a contour plot is that
we're going to take this graph and slice
it a bunch of times okay so i'm going to
slice it with various planes that are
all parallel to the x y plane
and let's think for a moment about what
these guys represent so the bottom one
here
represents the value
z is equal to negative two
okay so this is the z axis over here and
when we fix that to be negative 2 and
let x and y run freely we get this whole
plane
and if you
let z increase keep it constant but let
it increase by 1 to negative 1 we get a
new plane still parallel to the x y
plane
and it's got a
but its distance from the x y plane is
negative one and the rest of these guys
they're all still values constant values
of z
now in terms of our graph
what that means is that these represent
constant values of the graph itself
these represent constant values for the
function itself so because we always
represent the output of the function as
the height off of the x y plane these
represent
constant values for the output
so
what that's going to look like
so what we do
is we say where do these slices cut into
the graph
so i'm going to draw on all of the
points where those slices cut into the
graph and these are called contour lines
we're still in three dimensions so we're
not not done yet
so what i'm going to do is take all
these contour lines and i'm going to
squish them down onto the xy plane
so what that means
each of them has some kind of z
component at the moment and we're just
going to chop it down and squash them
all
nice and flat
onto the x y plane
and now we have something
two-dimensional and it still represents
some of the outputs of our function not
all of them it's not perfect but it does
give a very good idea so let's i'm going
to switch over to a two-dimensional
graph here
and this is that same
same function that we were just looking
at
let's actually move it
a little bit more central here so this
is the same function that we were just
looking at
but
each of these lines represents a
constant output of the function so it's
important to realize we're still
representing
a function that has a two dimensional
input and a one-dimensional output it's
just that we're looking in the input
space of that function as a whole so
this is still you know
f of
x y
and then some
expression of those guys but you know
this line might represent the constant
value of f when it all of the values
where it outputs three
over here this also
like both of these circles together give
you all the values where f outputs three
this one over here
will tell you where it outputs to and
you can't know this just looking at the
contour plot so typically if someone's
drawing it if it matters that you know
the specific values they'll mark it
somehow they'll let you know uh what
value each line corresponds to but as
soon as you know that you know this line
corresponds to zero it tells you that
every possible input point that sits
somewhere on this line will evaluate to
zero when you pump it through the
function
and this actually gives a very good feel
for the shape of things you know if you
like thinking in terms of graphs you can
kind of imagine how these circles and
everything would pop out of the page
you can also look you know notice how
the lines are really close together over
here very very close together but
they're a little more spaced over here
how do you interpret that
well
over here this means it takes a very
very small step to increase the value of
the function by one very small step and
it increases by one but over here it
takes a much larger step to increase the
function by the same value so over here
this kind of means steepness if you see
a very short distance between contour
lines
it's going to be very steep but over
here it's much more shallow
and you can do things like this to kind
of get a better feel for the function as
a whole the idea of a whole bunch of
concentric circles usually corresponds
to a maximum or a minimum
and you end up seeing these a lot
another another common
common thing people will do with contour
plots as they represent them is color
them
so what that might look like
is here
where you know warmer colors like orange
correspond to high values and cooler
colors like blue correspond to low
values
and
the contour lines end up going along you
know the division between red and green
here between light green and green and
that's another way where colors tell you
the output and then
the contour lines themselves can be
thought of as the borders between
different colors
and again a good way to get a feel for a
multi-dimensional function just by
looking at the input space